okay now I was at this play that I've
loved so much I've seen it twice now and
Juliet so and Juliet is a play where
what if Juliet didn't die with Romeo and
a lot of it is influenced by
Shakespeare's wife and her name is an
Hathaway then I did a little digging
what'd you learn there's a conspiracy
theory okay about your
husband and I feel like I actually just
need to bring up the picture that he
might be William Shakespeare
reincarnated because
look it's kind of nuts right I thought
it was I mean it it took seeing the
photo for me to go oh I should take this
seriously it's weird right hot
[Applause]
I why not commenting on that it's like
we're
back no it wouldn't it would be great if
it was true but even if it's not still
kind of great I love that your husband
does love that he's doesn't he he's cute
I don't want to like go on about it but
yeah the last time we talked the way you
talked about him I'm blushing and you've
been together you just celebrated 11
years uh 11 years married 15 years
together 15 15 years together and you
know what's crazy okay this is what this
is what's really crazy his and my second
date was at your Halloween party where
you were dressed up as Tippy hedrin from
the birds which is an inspiration for my
character and I goes full circle so
crazy and that was your second day youed
for each other I know I'm telling you
this is a thing like 15 years what do
you think that you do with and for each
other that keeps you speaking about each
other in this way that's so admiring and
loving you twinkle when you speak of him
I've seen you do it before I I mean I
think first of I think it's a little bit
a little bit just kind of luck of the
draw but we're just really lucky that we
keep growing together but um we have
this thing we actually have a tattoo and
the idea is that individually we're
whole but together we're more and so
thanks and uh and so um so I think that
it's just that thing about like I don't
expect him to complete me and I don't
think he expects me to complete him like
he's his own person I'm my own person
and we choose to be together because we
believe we make each other better and
this Union is something that we both
want to participate in but I just
watched an interview I hope this is cool
to bring up about you getting
interviewed by Johnny Carson when you
were seven yes and I was I remember it
very well I I mean which is wild to me I
tripped when I walked out too which
really humbled me because I was already
like you know 7 years old 1982 The
Tonight Show and I walked up to the
thing and I ate it really hard so I was
like so I'm laughing because I'm just
like yes you have YouTube to prove it
like it's but but I wasn't laughing at
the idea of a seven-year-old it on The
Tonight Show oh I am monster um but no
no but you were just I was just
marveling at you cuz I'm just like
you're so quick on your feet at 7 so
authentic So speaking from your heart
and like making a genuine connection and
it was just and then I watch you doing
this and you know how much I love you
know how proud I am you my God you know
how much I love you too this is like
life
[Music]
[Applause]
affirming